not something I would normally talk
about but this this is big because we
might be all screwed Net Neutrality I'm
sure you have heard it a ton I and I am
gonna try and keep this as contained as
I possibly can and not bore you with the
details but basically the FCC the body
that governs whether or not the internet
will remain open as it currently is or
will start getting locked off at the
discretion of your internet service
provider the FCC they are having a vote
in a couple of days about whether or not
they are going to remove the protections
that were put in place under the Obama
administration that ensured that all
websites all services and all users had
access to everything at the same speed
and ISPs were not allowed to throttle
and slow down any specific sites for
whatever reason they wanted to do that
and we know that they want to do that
because they had already started doing
it at the time the rule got put in place
I'm gonna put some links down below but
the main one you need to go to is battle
for the net you need to go there to get
the information about who your members
of Congress are and where their current
stance is on the net neutrality issue
because this is not being voted on by
the public the only chance we have at
this is to put as much pressure on our
members of Congress as we possibly can
that's a big part of why I'm making this
video because I have called my members
of Congress but I also live in one of
only five states in the country where
all my members of Congress have said
that they do support net neutrality if
you live anywhere other than Vermont
Delaware Rhode Island Hawaii or New
Hampshire then you have members of
Congress who are either against saving
that neutrality or have not made their
position clear and maybe could get
swayed either way if you pick up the
phone and if you think I'm only going on
about this because I'm a YouTube creator
this is going to impact everybody do you
love how with your cable or other TV
provider you can't just pay a baseline
and then get access to everything and if
you want certain things you have to pay
more and sometimes it comes bundled with
a bunch of stuff you didn't even want do
you love that no well that's what your
Internet's gonna start being alike
while it's fairly unlikely that Internet
service providers will start outright
blocking sites they can and they will
start throttling connection speed and
they're gonna do
in a couple of different ways for
starters they can start throttling the
connection speeds of the people actually
providing the internet sites that we
have they could charge Netflix YouTube
steam Facebook could start charging all
of these companies more money in order
to do the things that they're already
doing that puts their costs up so if any
of them charge you for anything they're
gonna have to start charging you more
because they're gonna take a massive hit
but in addition to that they're gonna
start hitting up you cuz remember that
comparison I just made to the cable
company well imagine you live in a
district where the ISP that you have
access to because let's be honest most
of us do not live in areas where we have
a ton of choice in terms of how many
different Internet service providers we
could go to so imagine the biggest ISP
in your area has cut a deal with
Microsoft and the only search engine
whose connection speed is gonna remain
at a good level is going to be Bing
because they put an exclusive deal so
Bing is included as part of your basic
package wait what's that you want to use
Google you mean like the vast majority
of the planet prefers well that's not
part of your basic package so you're
gonna have to pay for an upgrade to be
able to get Google added anything other
than a snail's pace did Oh YouTube did
Oh Facebook did Oh Netflix steam on and
on and on and on if this really goes
through which we know for a fact to the
current head of the FCC desperately
wants it to the only people who will
benefit from this are big communication
conglomerates they are the only ones it
is bad for the people who make anything
that uses the internet to sell a product
whether it is a digital product or a
physical product is bad for all of us
and it is bad for all of you who use the
Internet to access friggin anything the
arguments being made in favor of this
thing's are it will allow to give
consumers more choice I suppose
technically that's true and that you
will get a choice of how much more you
are willing to pay in order to do the
stuff that you're already doing and I
also want to shoot down the other
argument that usually happens with
situations like this which is that if we
make it so that the various
communication companies make more money
they'll create more jobs and it'll be
good for everyone well no they won't
because this isn't a situation where
it's going to allow them to expand and
create more jobs it's going to allow
them to throttle access to things there
are
doing in milk more money out of us that
way there is no need for them to hire
more people to be able to do that they
just start slowing down services they
can do that with the people they already
have why would they hire anyone new to
do that this is not a political issue
this is beyond a bipartisan issue if you
use the internet at all you should care
about this and we can't be complacent we
cannot assume that oh well you know I'm
sure what would happen yes it will
it absolutely will and more to the point
we have stopped stuff like this before
massive uprisings of the internet
community have stopped things like SOPA
and I can't even remember what the other
one was a couple years back this right
now what's about to happen
this is worse we have to do absolutely
everything every voice counts and as I
said I have already called my rep my
representatives in Congress even though
I know they are already in favor of
maintaining net neutrality I called
anyway because every single voice
matters we have risen up as a community
of Internet users in this nation to be
able to stop stuff like this before we
have to do it again because this could
be the worst thing that could possibly
happen on every conceivable level to the
internet it will be the cessation of
free expression of ideas where everybody
has access to the same resources both
outgoing incoming and suddenly you want
more ya pay more and buy more I mean
what you already have now you won't be
getting anything new you'll be getting
what you already had you'll just be
paying more money for it
help us tell these corporations and mr.
pie the current head of the FCC exactly
where they can stick it battle for the
net link down below again I wish I
didn't have to put this out this is not
the sort of content I want to be
spending my time creating but this
freaking matters and I'm not even gonna
put a prompt - if you have thoughts
comment about it this is not up for
debate this has to be stopped
period and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]